,
de véhicules de l'ONU.
DeCrCrCrCrCrCrCrCrCroix rouge
internationale, des civils
évacués, de présumés
retrouvailles...
Ces images de l'armée russe ne
donnent aucune information
sur la date de cette possible
évacuation de Marioupol.
Après des semaines de siège,
c'est une ville fantôme
que les Russes et
les séparatistes contrôlent.
Au milieu des ruines, ceux qui
ont décidé de rester tentent
de survivre. C'est le cas
de Kristina Bourdiouk,
pharmacienne et mère
de deux enfants.
KRISTINA BOURDIOUK,
résidente de Marioupol
"J'ai commencé à regarder
les cadavres et les explosions
avec plus de calme. J'ai compris
comment les gens vivent en Syrie
ou dans d'autres pays, dit-elle.
C'est très, très effrayant."
Pour l'instant, comme
les autres résidents,
elle peut compter sur cette aide
alimentaire frappée d'un Z,
symbole de l'invasion russe
en Ukraine pour survivre.
Kristina cherche un emploi,
celui qu'on lui propose c'est
de trier les décombres,
de sortir les cadavres,
de déminer, pour 32 000 roubles
par mois, l'équivalent de 450 $
Pour la famille Vorotylina,
il fallait quitter Marioupol
coûte que coûte. En rafistolant
leur voiture Lada, ravagée par
les bombardements, la mère,
ses deux filles et leur chien
sont arrivés sains et saufs
à Zaporijia.
"La seule chose qui
m'importait était la sécurité
de mes enfants.
De tous les enfants."
- Pour le ministre des Affaires
étrangères ukrainien, rien ne
garantit la réussite
des évacuations.
À Odessa, c'est un autre
bâtiment qui s'est effondré.
Ce port stratégique de la mer
Noire est sous les bombes russes
depuis des semaines, alors que
l'armée ukrainienne affirme
avoir détruit deux bateaux
patrouilleurs russes
au large de l'île aux Serpents.
Cette guerre est aussi celle
des mots. Les propos tenus
dimanche par le chef de
la diplomatie russe ont eu
l'effet d'une bombe.
"Hitler avait aussi du sang
juif", avait-il déclaré.
Des propos condamnés par
la communauté internationale
et par le président Zelensky,
qui dit qu'il n'y a pas de mots
assez forts pour dénoncer
le plus haut diplomate russe
qui blâme le peuple juif pour
les crimes nazis.
Au 68e jour de l'invasion
de l'Ukraine, Moscou annonce que
la guerre ne prendra pas fin
à la date symbolique du 9 mai,
jour de la victoire.
La Russie continue à grignoter
du terrain dans l'est du pays et
à pilonner des civils.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréa